- We're seconds away from season two
of the Drew Barrymore Show.
They say go big or go home,
but we're gonna do both.
Fire this thing up!
Because there truly is no place like home,
I'm going coast to coast
from New York to California
and everywhere in between to
celebrate all our hometowns.
So let's do this from the
place I was born and raised,
hello Hollywood.
This is the Drew Barrymore Show.
(audience cheering)
Hello everybody!
Hello, hello, hello.
Welcome, I can't believe we're here.
This is all for you guys
and it means so much to all of us,
because you are our very first
in-person studio audience.
(audience cheering)
We didn't have the privilege
of that in year one.
And what a way to kick things off.
We are here in my hometown of Hollywood.
(audience cheering)
At the iconic Paramount Studios.
My grandfather, John Barrymore shot here.
And I love that, hello, hello.
I am so excited for our very first guest.
She may be the biggest star on the planet.
We've worked together,
we've laughed together
and I cannot believe right now
that we're actually here together.
It's total kismet because
she's here to help us
kick off our second season
of this daytime show.
I know!
And she jumps into the second
season of her upcoming series,
"The Morning Show".
And when I say that acting
doesn't get better than this.
I mean it with every fiber of my being,
please welcome the
magnanimous, Jennifer Aniston.
(audience cheering)
- Oh no, we can't hug.
It's so stupid.
- I'll also get down, do some of that.
- Hi babe.
Hi.
(audience cheering)
Hi, this is.
First of all, seeing you in the flesh,
cause I've been watching
this and you're so good.
You're so good at this.
Honestly.
I love every single bit of it,
you get stains out of your (bleeps).
I mean, someone said
to me, oh, what was it?
Well, I've already put
a stain on your chair
because of my body makeup.
You're dying for that, right?
This has been in your
blood for a long time.
- Yes, yes.
It really did start when I was like 14
living in my first apartment
and that there was a
laundry mat down the street
and I would get into that
washer like it was a cauldron
and I was a witch.
Fabric softeners, stain removal,
bleach, the whole art of,
and I think that's where it was born.
- It also holds the sentence
14, my own apartment.
- It's you know, we're--
- This girl has live it.
- Well, we're going
through a journey today.
- Yes.
- And I wanted to take this
intimate tour of Los Angeles
that really showed every
place that I've lived.
- Do you still have the house
that I've been to a few times?
- I sold it actually.
- No!
- I know, that was a very
painful thing for me.
A very scary thing for me
to leave my one anchor.
- That was your anchor.
- When you moved from New York to LA,
what were the feelings?
What was that experience like
to let go and start anew?
- Yeah.
Well, let go and start anew,
I don't think anybody moving,
going from New York to LA ever
actually says, I'm moving.
You're going on a vacation
that then just keeps extending itself
because you're almost too
afraid to say as an actor,
I'm going to go try to
make it in California.
Because I didn't make it
in New York for two years,
God knows I'm gonna make it in LA.
So I'm just gonna go visit my father.
And then I landed and I knew one person.
And then I met another person
who then let introduce,
and then I went into this little party,
a little house party in Laurel
Canyon, with maybe 12 people.
Next thing you know,
I'm in a goddess circle
in Laurel Canyon.
And I, all of a sudden had someone,
I couldn't just talk,
you have a talking stick.
I was like, wow, I am really,
I have landed in Los Angeles.
And then I was, I had a job
at a telemarketing company,
like in, I don't even know
where it was, selling--
- What were you selling?
- Pocono timeshares.
And then I did get a job.
So I moved from Studio
City, I met these people,
this group of people,
and they all had rentals on
this street in Laurel Canyon
called Beach Nell Road.
- Yup.
- One lived here, one
lived here, one lived here
and they would all sort
of visit each other.
There was one house that
everyone kind of congregated in.
And then one night I was there.
They were like, "This
one's available for rent."
So then I got myself up on the hill
and we were called the hill people.
Lived this fun few years
doing jobs here and there
and then "Friends" happened,
which I thought I'd kind of manifested.
Cause I said, "This is sort
of the way I live on the hill,
where you have your friends.
And everybody shows up at the house,
at Monica and Rachel's."
I was like, "I feel very,
this is very familiar to me."
- Do you believe that
you do manifest things
like one is capable
- Yes.
- Of manifesting?
- I've been told to
manifest whatever it is
that you are wanting to manifest.
You speak to it as though
it's already happened.
- Okay, I like that.
- So thank you for this wonderful job
that I have dreamed about and prayed for
and with this glorious crew
and a joyful experience.
Thank you for that.
(audience cheering)
- Now it's hard to pass by
the career that you've had
and jump to the next one.
And then we're gonna go backwards.
But Adam Sandler.
(audience cheering)
Who is someone that--
- [Jennifer] The sand man.
- [Drew] The sand man.
- [Jennifer] The sand man can.
- Adam is, he's one of a kind isn't he?
- He's a unicorn.
- Yes, he really is.
- He's a unicorn because he's a joy.
He walks with joy, lives with
joy and he doesn't get moody.
Yeah, comedians are moody.
- And I'm attracted to
them because I want them
to make me laugh in real life.
- Yes.
- And--
- Let your girlfriends do that.
- Yeah, totally.
- Yeah.
- Okay so there was this
Twitter debate that happened
about who is a better
partner for Adam Sandler,
Jennifer Aniston or Drew Barrymore?
Which sounds weird to say my name.
And what I loved about
what came out of that was--
- What?
- Was that you and I chose each other.
- Oh, well that's a no brainer.
Yeah.
That's because, there's the
phrase the guys like to say,
bros before hoes.
- Oh my god, I was gonna
say hoes before bros.
- Always.
- And that is sisterhood.
- [Jennifer] That's right.
- And we have had that
and you have it with your friends.
And we just celebrate that.
And I loved that that was the true answer.
- Yeah.
- We've got to take a quick break,
but she's not going anywhere.
We'll have more with Jennifer
Aniston right after this.
(audience cheering)
- Please don't make me go
back in there, come on.
- I'm saying this as a friend, Alex,
we don't know what's
gonna be in Maggie's book.
- Oh, that sounds like you do know
what's gonna be in Maggie's book.
- No I don't, I know her
editor, but she won't tell me.
But whatever it is, this
gives you the opportunity
to go in there and respond
without looking like you're responding.
To defend yourself.
- Jesus!
What am I defending myself about
that I didn't already admit
on national television?
(audience cheering)
- Welcome back, we are here
with America's sweetheart
and someone who just is the
coolest person on the planet,
Jennifer Aniston.
(audience cheering)
You know, "The Morning Show".
- [Jennifer] Yes!
(audience cheering)
- What are you channeling in that?
Because it's the greatest thing
I've ever seen as an actress
and in your body of work.
- It was basically about just
revisiting some of the shadows
blind spots that I put
into a particular file
and meeting them head on
and actually releasing them.
It was like a extraordinary therapy
better than any actual therapist
that I've been going to
for years on end.
Because--
- Do you think that Alex
Levy is the closest character
to you or that you've blessed it
with some of your deepest truths
behind her?
- I think it's
a little bit of both.
Alex Levy is people someone
may be in particular
who I have witnessed in my life.
People, it's a combination of people
who I have watched and I remember thinking
I don't want to ever do that.
I don't want to be that.
Then there is sort of
the tapping into the part
that wants to have that scream
into your pillow and yell,
which I never was able to do because,
until I did it in front
of 150 crew member.
- [Drew] Because you
wouldn't let yourself?
- I wouldn't let myself.
I didn't know how to,
I like to discuss things,
like to have a conversation,
a rational conversation,
because if you're ever with
someone who's a screamer,
nothing gets done.
I just go shut down, shut down, shut down.
- What was it about
this point in your life
that you were like, was it
that I have nothing to lose?
- It's written.
It was written for me,
it was written for me.
It was written, we talked about it.
There is a part, as you get older
that you just hit a wonderful,
who gives a rats (bleeps)?
This is just my moment.
(audience cheering)
True.
- Right?
Yes.
I thank you for sharing
that with the world
because it's cathartic for us watching it.
- Thank you.
- [Drew] I'm serious.
I just marvel.
- Thank you.
- I marvel, I marvel, I marvel.
- I can't wait to do a
comedy, let me tell you that.
- [Drew] Well--
- Rush me to a comedy immediately
after completing that second season.
- I mean, now when I think of hair,
obviously you're the most
famous head of hair we've got,
seriously, come on the Rachel, hello?
(audience cheering)
So when I hear that
you're doing hair care.
I'm like, "Give it to me now."
I'm on the feeder, tell me about LolaVie.
- It comes out of many years
of having really unruly hair.
That's always been my struggle.
I paired myself with
these wonderful people
that used to be part of Arden,
and maybe five years ago,
we started working on this
and we're doing one product at a time
because it has to be perfect.
And that was the first one we started.
Cause I live for a good detangler.
Cause when you know you
rip through your hair,
when it's wet is half the damage.
- I heard a hot tip.
When your hair is wet,
use a wide tooth comb
because your follicle
is at its most fragile.
- Yes.
- Please do not use a
brush and break through it.
- Especially a really
bristly brush is death
or there's actually wet brushes
that are made for wet hair.
- I do love that wet brush.
- I love a wet brush,
I just discovered it.
- Oh my god, I have minis for my kids.
And they're all over the house.
- They have minis?
- Yes, you travel with them.
- Oh god.
- I'm gonna get you so many wet brushes
you're not gonna believe.
- I'm just not gonna know
what to do with myself.
- Okay, we're gonna go to
a quick commercial break.
And then when we come back,
we're gonna put Jen and
some of our game skills
to the test.
- Oh boy.
- And we're gonna play
the classic game show.
"Let's Make A Deal" because
Wayne Brady himself is here
to play.
And we might have something
important for dogs in it.
- [Jennifer] I hope.
- This is all about you and the rescues,
we'll be right back.
- [Jennifer] Okay.
(audience cheering)
- We're back with the very
charming Jennifer Aniston
and we're about to play
"Let's Make A Deal"
to hopefully win some
money for these puppies
from Wagmore Pets, a dog rescue,
and you have a very special
connection with Wagmore.
- I do.
I had my latest Lord Chesterfield
was rescued from Wagmore.
- Well, everyone knows
that I love a game show
and who doesn't and what better way
to kick off Los Angeles week
than a classic game show,
"Let's Make A Deal".
(audience cheering)
So everybody welcome Wayne Brady.
Hello.
- Hi Wayne Brady.
Pleasure.
- Can you handle it?
- No, he could be yours though.
- I already got four, I
already got four, hey y'all.
- All right, Wayne.
Thank you for honoring
us with your presence.
- Oh it's my pleasure.
- [Drew] I just visited
you in your premiere week.
- Yes ma'am.
- So thank you for coming.
Today tell us what we are playing for.
- All right, so if you
know, "Let's Make A Deal",
you know that we love to
make a deal of course.
So we're gonna play a game
called how much is enough.
Now, easy-peasy game.
This first prize that you're playing for,
it is a picture of us on the
set of "Let's Make A Deal".
Now, do you keep this
picture as amazing as it is
and just walk away, it's yours
or do you take a silver envelope?
And that silver envelope
will be brought into me
by the money fairy, AKA Chris
Haheard, one of our producers
thank you money fairy.
- With all due respect to both of us.
I think I'm going to go with the--
- Silver.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- Silver envelope.
Now, you know, this could be a zonk.
- [Drew] A zonk.
- But it isn't, it's $25,000.
- [Drew] Oh my god.
- So you've got $25,000 for Wagmore.
Now you can keep your
$25,000 and your picture
and just walk away.
Or you could take this gold envelope.
If--
(audience cheering)
If you decide to take the gold envelope
and there's a zonk inside,
then you lose everything.
- [Audience Member] Go gold.
- [Wayne] That sounds like peer pressure.
- We're gonna go for
yes Wayne, please gosh.
- Remember what I said
that if this was a zonk,
you lose everything?
- [Jennifer] Yes we remember.
- Okay.
I just got to reiterate.
- I know.
- Another $25,000.
Another $25,000 for Wagmore,
you now have $50,000.
- Yes.
(audience cheering)
- Plus the picture, which I'm
so happy that you get that
because I'm a dog dad, I've got four dogs,
so yay Wagmore.
- Yay.
- Money fairy, the big envelope please.
Thank you.
If this is a zonk, you lose everything.
So you can walk away right
now with your 50 grand.
- Remember we talked about
not wanting to be greedy
and not being ambitious.
- I think we stick with this.
- I do too.
- Stick it.
- So you're passing on the envelope?
- Oh god, yes yes.
- Oh come on.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- You guys have shot
films all over the world.
Have you ever shot in Hungary?
- No, no, he hates the idea.
- And I'm Hungarian.
- Oh puppy it's okay.
- Because what you passed on,
this is a zonk and little know that zonk
is actually the Hungarian translation
of he's just not that into you.
- Oh!
- So congratulations,
you missed out on a zonk.
Let's hear it for Wagmore.
Jennifer Aniston, Drew
thank you for making
- Thank you so much.
- Pleasure.
- He is so cute.
- Thank you so much, that's $50,000.
- [Jennifer] $50,000, that's amazing.
- Sure.
- I mean you've just, by the way, come on.
- Don't pee on me baby.
- I think it's good.
All right that's $50,000
and it'll go towards
Wagmore Pet Dog Rescue.
(audience cheering)
Which Jennifer Aniston has
brought to the forefront
of our attention.
It's an extraordinary
organization right here,
but you can support it from
all across the country.
We want to send a huge thank you
to The Wildest,
your go-to pet parents site
and pet DNA decoder, Wisdom
Panel for your donations
and supporting Wagmore Pet Dog Rescue.
Those are the two companies
that gave us the $25,000.
- Yay.
- And thank you so much
for supporting Wagmore.
Go to TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
to find out more information
on The Wildest, Wisdom Panel
and Wagmore Pet Dog Rescue,
and Wayne thank you so
much for doing this.
- Thanks for having me.
- Pleasure to see you Wayne.
- Be sure to check out "Let's
Make A Deal" today on CBS.
"The Morning Show" premieres
September 17th on Apple TV.
We'll be right back, thank you.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
Welcome back to our
season two premiere show
coming to you from sunny
Los Angeles, California.
(audience cheering)
We really do have amazing weather here.
And today we're celebrating
a Drew Gooder right here
and she's from Watts, South Los Angeles,
and has spent the last 50
years educating children
from underserved communities.
Take a look at her story.
- Hi, I'm Dolores Sheen AKA aunt Dolores.
And I'm the executive
director and co-founder
of the Sheenway School and Culture Center
in Watts, South LA.
The school opened in 1971, 50 years ago
and we're still here.
Reaching and teaching.
I was gonna be a doctor,
I dropped out of school,
took Montessori courses
so I could be an educator.
Our curriculum is enriched
and we use everything we can
in our power to develop and
encourage critical thinking,
sign language, drama, music.
We have a cricket club, the
first cricket club in the hood.
I teach harp, violin, cello, bass, piano.
We had all these pumpkins
in our little garden
and that's how the
Sheenway Bakery was born.
The Chow Wagon was launched
on June 10th of this year
to allow the children
to serve a community.
- Come get your delicious pumpkin bread.
- I'm never gonna retire
because as long as I can give,
I think I'll live.
It's a good feeling when you know
that someone's gonna walk out
knowing more than they did
when they came in and
you had a part of it.
I think that's why I
love children so much.
Sorry.
It's like good in the hood.
(Dolores laughing)
(audience cheering)
- Welcome live and in person Dolores Sheen
AKA aunt Dolores.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
- And I understand you
brought two special gentlemen
here today.
- Yeah some good cooks.
This is Marcus and that's Jordan.
(audience cheering)
- Marcus, I'd like to ask
what your favorite thing
is about being a part of this community?
- It's fun.
And it's physical education.
- I love that you summed up
one word that speaks volumes.
And Jordan, what about for you?
- I liked the food.
- I think something all people
can relate to and appreciate.
And you also have Sheenway's
sister school in Ghana, Africa.
Will you please tell
us about that program?
- Our school here is an underserved area
of what they call South LA in the hood.
Our school in Ghana is in the bush.
It's like an underserved area.
We were the first
registered private school
in the Volta Region.
(audience cheering)
- And you guys brought
some baked goods for us.
And these are treats from
the Sheenway Bakery, right?
- Yes.
The students own and operate their bakery
because there's a history
of why we have the bakery
and the history stems from
when the community and Richard Pryor
helped us get a peace treaty
with the bloods and the crips
that's two of the main gang factions.
And we wanted to say, thank you.
And that year we had a lot
of pumpkins in our garden.
So I said, let's try and
make some pumpkin bread.
And they said, let's get
Richard Pryor's help.
So he loved the pumpkin bread
and that's how the bakery got started.
And not only that, he
came back three times
to talk with the dialogue.
And that set a different
perspective on the community.
Someone knows we're here.
Someone knows our pain.
That was more than any money
or anything anybody could give.
And to this day he is our hero.
- Oh.
- To this day.
(audience cheering)
- The layers of importance and
beauty just keep unfolding.
And we also have some special
people joining us right here
in the audience who are proud of you
and what you have done for your community.
Please welcome principal Roy Satakane,
faculty and alumni from
the Sheenway School, hello.
(audience cheering)
Dolores we have a--
- Alright three cheers
for aunt Dolores.
Hip hip hooray,
hip hip hooray.
- Hooray.
- Hip hip hooray.
I love that, principle Roy,
what is your hope for Sheenway
in the next 50 years?
- Currently, as aunt Delores had mentioned
we have a school in South Sokode, Ghana,
and we're starting a new
digital infrastructure
that will connect our Los Angeles school
to the school in South Sokode, Ghana.
- Well you're gonna need support.
And you deserve that.
And to commemorate your 50th anniversary,
our friends at Conagra Brands Foundation
are donating $20,000
to the Sheenway School
and Educational Center
in Watts, California.
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
Thank you, Dolores.
Thank you, Marcus and
Jordan, principal Roy
and everyone at the Sheenway
School and Cultural Center
in Watts.
For more information, you can go
on our website at TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
to support this incredible institution.
And we'll be right back.
Thank you aunt Dolores.
- Ah!
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- Welcome back.
I still cannot believe
that we get to launch
our second season from Hollywood.
(audience cheering)
To make the most of this
moment right now and honor it
in a way it truly deserves.
I wanted to take a look back
at some of the places that shaped me
and I wanted to take you with me.
This is an intimate tour of my LA.
I'm gonna take us to
the first place I lived
until I was seven years old.
Hang on to your hat.
They've really made it
look so much more romantic.
The bars were on the windows
because it just wasn't safe enough,
but the neighborhood's
gotten so much better.
God I'm so tempted to just
beg them to let me in.
(gentle music)
I don't have to be lonely anymore.
I was so lonely in this house.
It was just me and my mom.
And it was just a really sad energy.
It was very empty and very lonely.
And I grew up and got in
charge of my own destiny.
And now my house is like
Grand Central Station.
There's so much life and
there's so many people
and this place just taught me
that I wasn't the kind of
person who wanted to live
in a quiet, lonely place.
I wanted to live a life where
I was around a lot of people.
(upbeat music)
I learned to drive at Sophia
Loren's ranch in Calabasas.
Her two sons, Carlo and Edoardo taught me
in a Renault Le car.
And they taught me on a stick shift.
Oh my god, when I was trying
to attempt sleeping at night,
even though I was just so scared,
this is what cats sound
like when they are mating.
Are you ready?
(Drew making cat mating sounds)
That was the soundtrack to this apartment.
As much as the building looks charming,
back in the 70s,
there was a lot of like, don't
park your car at night alone.
There's bars on the windows.
There's bars on the individual apartments.
I mean, for a 14 year old, I was scared
and I'm not scared anymore.
I'm not scared anymore at all.
I definitely am glad that
my kids, no matter what,
cause we're gonna, all of
us are gonna screw it up
with our kids, we're gonna do our best,
but we're gonna make mistakes.
I'm so glad that my kids
won't be having to live
on their own at 14.
And that's as healing to the
14 year old me as it can get.
Oh, this is it.
Oh my god, it's still here.
The Washing Machine.
This is such a dream to be here.
I spent years here.
When I first lived in my
apartment that I was so scared in,
the truth was is that I would
let the laundry and dishes
and everything pile up.
I didn't know how to clean,
but this was where I learned
how to take care of myself.
The books were the school and
this was the domestic journey
of learning how to live on your own.
Kids don't know how to
take care of themselves
until you teach them.
Olive and Frankie, I'm coming for you.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
That was the start of
my stain removal story.
You know we have a segment on our show
called Stan for Stains,
and I absolutely just
loved taking this tour
and sharing it with you.
That's why I did it,
including our last stop it's
a place I haven't been back to
in a long time.
It's the institution where
I spent a year and a half
of my life and take a look.
(upbeat music)
It's right here.
- [Lady] The place with
all the barbed wire?
- Yeah that's it.
I was a real wild child and
I just got so out of control
that no one knew what to do with me.
And so my mom called a friend
because her daughter was out of control
and they drove me here in
the middle of the night
and they walked me right
through those two doors.
And when you go through those two doors,
you do not come out.
And I was there for a year and a half.
I think this is important
for me to share with people
because when they watch our show,
we have a very beautiful set
and I get to dress in nice clothing
and get my hair and makeup done.
And there's an elegance
hopefully to the show,
but I will never lose sight
of this part of my story.
And I have seen and been through things
and they've helped me just
recognize in all of us
that we go through steps and
it can't be embarrassing.
It has to be our strengths.
It has to be something
that we can be proud of
because we overcame it and we look back
with honor and humor.
Life is so wonderful compared
to what it was in this place.
I can't even believe I actually
get to be where I am now.
Cause when I was here, I didn't see that,
I thought I would be here forever.
I never thought I was gonna
make it to somewhere better.
And I'm just so happy with my life.
And I don't know if I
would have the life I have
if it wasn't for a place like this.
So
it was so important to come here today,
just honor this.
It's very empowering.
It's very celebratory.
I just get to visit it in
my dreams and wave hello
and know I'm not here anymore.
That's pretty cool.
Welcome to the Drew Barrymore Show.
Where we like to keep it real.
(audience cheering)
Thank you for taking the time
to be so intimate with me.
I really appreciate it.
And there's so much more
actually to this tour.
So if you go to our website
at TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com,
right now, you can watch the full version
and we will be right back.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
Hollywood is simply one of
the coolest places in Cali.
It happens to be where
I was born and raised
and lived my whole life
in the 90046 area code.
There are so many reasons
to visit this area.
The iconic Hollywood sign
is certainly one of them,
but there is amazing food
and interesting neighborhoods
to walk around
and old Spanish Hollywood
architecture to marvel at.
By the way, could you
tell I'm from California?
I mean, I am stuck with this
accent for my whole life
and I couldn't be more proud.
If there's anything
more Cali about someone
than this kind of accent,
I'd like to meet them.
Drew's Cali is sponsored
by Visit California.
(audience cheering)
Welcome back, cheers.
It's time for Drew's News.
The only news that wonders
how you've been all summer.
And with me at the desk, this season,
the co-pilot of my news
dreams, Rossy Ross Matthew.
- Hello, we're back!
I have missed you so much.
And what a way to kick
off season two Drew.
- I mean, I was a girl alone in a box
until you came and rescued me Rossy.
- Oh, I was your knight in shining armor.
- Your are my knight in shining armor.
- More like knight in
sequence but I'll take it.
Thank you Drew.
- True, true, true.
All right we're gonna jump right in
with this epic movie news.
Apparently everyone in
Hollywood is starring
in "Don't Look Up" and it's
the new movie by Adam McKay.
Adam McKay has done everything.
"Vice".
- "Vice",
"Anchorman".
- Yeah.
- "Big Short".
- Yes.
He's a genius.
The trailer's out now and Variety reports
that Leonardo DiCaprio, so hot,
and Jennifer Lawrence also so hot
star as two astronomers
trying to save the world
from total destruction.
It's a reality movie.
Thank god, just kidding.
It's not, it's fictional, take a look.
- There is a comet headed
directly towards earth.
- Do you know how many
the world is ending meetings we've had
over the last two years?
- Drought, famine, hole
in the ozone is so boring.
- I mean, Meryl Streep is
the fricking president.
- [Ross] Yes.
(audience cheering)
Meryl Streep, you got my
vote thank you so much.
- [Drew] I want her to be
the president for real.
- I know secretary of state,
Diane Keaton, I'll take it.
- Absolutely, Diane,
please come on this show.
We are, I mean please.
We stalk her, we stan Diane Keaton.
I mean, hello.
- Hello!
You look like the Annie
hall of fame right now.
- Ms. Diane Keaton please take
my hand in fashion marriage,
and please grace us with your presence.
God, we love her so much.
And guess what?
- [Ross] What?
- We have more good news Ross.
- Oh yeah, so Jennifer
Lawrence, did you hear this?
People report she's got a bun in the oven
and it's not sourdough.
She is expecting her first
child with her husband,
art gallery director Cooke Maroney.
(audience cheering)
I love her so much.
And do you know what you call it
when a pregnant Jennifer
Lawrence has cravings?
Hunger games (laughs).
- You know--
- No, don't clap.
- I have a story about Jennifer Lawrence.
- [Ross] Tell me everything.
- Okay I was at lunch with
her, me and Cameron Diaz.
So we're in the restaurant
and we see this guy outside
and he looks like a
paparazzi and he's on a moped
and he's got cameras and we're like,
"Oh, we're all in the restaurant."
And we just showed up looking crappy
and we're all just like,
"Oh god, it's that moment."
And we're like, "You know what?
Let's just go out."
And he was a nature photographer,
had no interest in us
and boy did we feel stupid.
- Oh that's hilarious.
- And it was hilarious.
And we all just had a big
laugh at our own expense.
- Oh I love that.
- We were like, "Oh he doesn't care at all
about the three of us.
He is a birdwatcher."
- But he missed like
the best picture ever.
Can you imagine?
Wow.
- Okay, I'm very
interested to get your take
on this next story Rossy
because a new study from the
American Institute of Physics
found that heterosexual
women consistently rated men
who speak less clearly
are more attractive.
- [Ross] What?
- What?
- The mumbling got these
ladies motors rumbling.
And now Previous Science
found that straight men
on the other hand were
more attracted to women
who clearly speak and annunciate.
You heard me.
- Oh I heard you.
- We're gonna get Tanya's
take who is right here
in the audience.
And you say that you love
a mumbling man, Tanya.
- Yes, I do actually.
And he's sitting next to me.
- Oh no.
- Hi.
- So, okay, what was the
draw other than the mumbling?
- He was trying to ask me out.
He was mumbling and I found
it very cute and attractive.
That felt like he was kind of shy
and some sensitive side
in him for some reason,
three years later, he
asked me to marry him.
He proposed and he mumbled it again.
- Can you do an impression,
how did he do it?
- Well, he couldn't say it,
but he wrote it down in a little note
and he gave me some
roses and he had the ring
and then he was like,
"Would you marry me baby?"
That's what it said on the note.
And I clearly understood
that's what he was asking.
- Gus, why do you think that
you just are so darn charming?
- Well, first of all, I was really nervous
because she's so beautiful and
you I just started mumbling
and I couldn't get it right.
And so when I wanted
to ask her to marry me,
I was like, "I'm gonna mumble again."
And so I wrote it down just in case
so that she can get the message.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you, Tanya and
Gus, this was so fun.
It's our first official news in Hollywood.
- I know and we've got an audience.
Thank you guys.
- We love you guys, we'll be right back.
- [Ross] Amazing.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] All week,
it's an all out all star
Hollywood premier events.
Next Drew, after two decades,
the cast of "Never Been Kissed" reunited.
- I am Josie Grossy!
(audience cheering)
- [Narrator] Plus RuPaul
helps Drew go back to school
and get her diploma.
- All new Drew from Hollywood.
On the next Drew Barrymore Show.
(audience cheering)
I just got an orchid cause
I just got it two days ago.
Welcome back.
All right it's almost time to go.
But before we do,
we love to leave you with
a little something to go
and we like to call it the Doggy Bag.
(dogs barking)
There it goes.
And today we're talking about a product
that I am a huge fan of
and I hope you guys are gonna love it.
It what?
- [Ross] Uh Drew.
(audience cheering)
Oh.
What ah!
Hello.
- Look who's here.
- Look at this.
- [Phil] What's up?
- [Drew] I'm so happy to see you.
- Well, I heard you
were shooting on the lot
and I've been here so long
I'm like the welcome wagon.
So I brought you a welcome basket
and your grandfather shot a
lot of movies here, right?
So I found some photos
of him on the lot here.
So how about that?
- That is so sweet.
- Hollywood lot.
- Hello.
That is so sweet.
- You know I knew that he was here,
but I didn't have any
photographic evidence of it.
- Yeah well there you go.
And I've got something
even more special for you.
This is amazing.
You know, he shot one of
the most iconic movies ever.
This is the original poster
for "Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde"
from the 20s.
- [Ross] Aw.
- Okay.
- I'm gonna put these up immediately.
I love that you're gonna be
associated with these moments
because you're bringing
me closer to my roots.
- You're welcome and thank
you for being my friend
and welcome to the Paramount lot.
Do not park in my spot.
- I won't.
- I will let you finish your
show and do what you do.
- I love you, thank you
so much, I love it.
- All right guys,
see you, so long.
- Well, thank you Ross.
Thank you, Dr. Phil.
"House Calls with Dr. Phil"
actually airs Wednesdays
at 9:00 PM on CBS
and season 20 of "Dr. Phil" air's weekdays
and you check your
local listings for that.
I want to thank all of our
guests and I feel so lucky
and I just.
- [Male Audience Member] Love you Drew.
- I love you guys.
Thank you for everyone watching at home,
or on the go.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
(audience cheering)
(gentle music)
(upbeat music)